could keep all of that data so that if we
needed to like reach out to the customer,
anything we would have at all.
So I usually send out probably like somewhere
from 3,000 to 5,000 every Monday and Thursday
and then I get probably like a thousand responses
to 2000 per week, I would say. So like for
the year of 2025, we had like, I think like
30 some thousand responses. And that's just
on one of our surveys. So the like I said
we're a utility company and I'm kind of telling
you more about the water side because we
also have a gas business, but we're going
through like a merger right now, so we're
not sure what's happening with the gas business.
So our focus is more on the water side.
Makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, sorry, I'm like rambling. I don't
know if I'm answering.
You are giving me really good information.
And Julia, there are actually two things
that you just mentioned.
So on SurveyMonkey. Oh my God. That's like
a massive data set that you are actually
collecting from your customer. That's really
massive. And I'm curious.
So you mentioned that automated report from
Qlik and what about the data that you collect
from, from Like a survey monkey. Like how,
like what's your process like for creating
a report based on this? Like a massive data
set.
Yeah, so we are still pretty old fashioned
here. I use Excel for like a lot.
Like I have a file that I download all of
our data into. I will say I do like a decent
amount of analyzing in SurveyMonkey itself.
Like sometimes I'll. I'll just go to the
analyze results page and like use that to
like kind of share what's going on.
But I share like a dashboard out of which
is literally just the data I put in Excel
and then I make like tables and graphs into
Excel with it. Like I said, our CX program's
like pretty small, so there's not a ton of
people we share the results with. But it's
growing so we're getting there.
Yeah, I mean for sure. And Julia, could I
also ask, you know you mentioned that you
sometimes rely on the survey monkeys like
analyze features and related to that point,
I'm curious whether how AI, if at all has
involved in your data analysis or reporting
process.
Yes. I actually have two things about that.
The first being you guys have the Analyze
with AI feature. I've tried to use that but
I think I was in touch with someone before
and they said that the size of my survey
was just too big to use it. I don't know
if that's still the case, but.
So I would really like to use that but I
think with the amount of responses we're
getting, it's just too big to use. And then
I've used AI like outside of SurveyMonkey
so our open ended feedback is like huge for
us. So I'll export like all of our comments
or responses to open ended questions and
sometimes I'll upload them to like Copilot
and say can you pull out like common themes?
Because I use the tagging feature and I'll
try to tag like pretty much every comment
that comes in. It's really time consuming
but I'll be like, I know that this group
of comments is about whatever I tagged it
with.
Can you tell me like the more specific themes
that are in there?
So I think that would be like cool if I can.
I don't know if your analyze with AI feature
does that and I just can't use it, but that
would be cool if I could do that within SurveyMonkey.
Interesting. So when you say tagging feature
that this is more of manual process that's
happening in Excel, right. And then no.
So you're like, you know how you can put
a tag on it within SurveyMonkey.
I see, I see, I see.
Yeah, I tag them, tag them, download,
export, and then to copilot to generate based
on those text. Perfect.
And Julia, I'm also curious, like, when you.
I guess, I guess more general question, like,
what really stands out to you about using,
you know, copilot in your data analysis process?
Like, either positive or negative, it's saved
me a lot of time because I was trying to
manually get like samples of feedback and
try and like generalize the themes within
them myself. And uploading to CO when I was
doing that, I did come up with some things,
but obviously I can't read through like thousands
and thousands of comments on my own.
So putting them in CO pilot has just saved
me like a ton of time. And then they'll.
They'll give me like, themes that they're
seeing repetitively. And I've compared it
to kind of like some of what I've done on
my own and they do seem to match. So I'm.
I trust it for the most part. I know it's
like experimental kind of, but it has saved
me a ton of time.
Interesting. And I actually find the point
that you just mentioned about. Okay, so here
are outputs from copilot.
But then I think I heard you say you compare
the outputs to what you have already done
before and help me understand what this process
is about. Like, why is this comparison something
that matters to you?
So I am in school, I went to school for statistics
and I'm in grad school for stat. So, like,
a lot of the integrity of like, what's in
the data matters a lot to me. Like, I wouldn't
want to just upload it to Copilot and then
trust everything they say without validating
some of it myself.
So I've just taken like a sample of whatever's
relevant out of the group I'm exporting and
read through them manually myself and assign
them, like, with patterns that like, I've
defined and then just matched up to see what
copilot's saying to see if they kind of like
align. Because I wouldn't, I wouldn't want
to like throw up the results from copilot
on something without having validated it
myself.
Interesting. That makes sense. And how do
you feel in general?
Like, how do you feel about that validation
process?
I think it's just really time consuming.
Like, I would love to save time doing that.
I also think it's nice that I can validate
it myself, but nobody else is really, like,
Doing that with me. So it's kind of just
all me on my own.
I mean, I trust my opinions, but I don't
know if like I would really like, I don't
know, it's just time consuming and it's hard
to know if I'm always like doing the right
thing with it.
Interesting. And thanks so much for sharing
that with me. And just to get a little bit
clarification on the process, is it much
like that you select like a sample of outputs
from copilot and also a sample from your
own analysis and make that like one to one
comparison Rather than comparing all the
key findings against all all the key findings
that you did on your own.
It's more like I will do a sample and then
I'll upload more than that to copilot.
Like I'll give like, I'll take like a hundred
out of a thousand comments and manually do
it. But for copilot, like I'll give them
all 1000 comments and say like, can you please
pull out like the common themes you're seeing?
That makes sense. Okay, Julia, this is such
a nice segue to our next topic, which is
the feature itself. Okay.
Okay. Have you tried out the feature before
our session?
Yes. And I took some notes just to try to
have stuff to hopefully answer your questions.
But I love that.
Thank you so much. Okay. So Julia, do you
feel comfortable to log into your SurveyMonkey
SurveyMonkey account, open the report and
do you feel comfortable to share your screen
with me so that we can have more interactive
conversation about the report?
Yeah, I have it open.
Amazing.
I really appreciate you making notes. This
is really important. This is really like
happy surprise for me. So thank you.
Yeah, I was like, I didn't know if it would
be like more of me having to talk or you
talking.
So I was like, I should be ready.
50%. 50%. Okay. Before we dive into this
report, tell me, tell me, tell me a little
bit about this survey, the purpose of this.
Yeah, so you know how I was telling you we
do, we have a gas company and a water company.
It's the same survey on both sides, but for
some reason I just generated it for the gas
side.
I think I might have done it for the water
one when you first told me about the feature.
But I just focused more on this when I was
like going through it. It's a feedback survey
for the call center. So it's like a 10 question,
less than 10 question survey.
Okay, that makes a lot of sense.
And Julia, I want you to Pretend I'm your
colleague outside of the CS program. I want
to learn about this report and could you
actually just briefly, briefly walk me through
each section and just help me understand
what each section is about.
Yeah. So the summary, I really like the summary
because I feel like it's something that I
could like take outside of my department
just to kind of like share what's going on.
But I did see something in there that I could
kind of like use clarification on. I think
like so these first couple sentences like
I, I like how it's saying customer satisfaction.
The results reveal that the most critical
factor influencing CSAT is the ability to
resolve issues on the first contact. I loved
when I read that because like we're trying
to emphasis so much on first call resolution
that I thought that was like so helpful.
But then when I got down to the open ended
feedback part here we have like several questions
that are open ended and some of them you
only get if you respond positively.
Like we use the logic feature on a previous
question. You will only get one if you respond
positively and then you get a different one
if you respond negatively. So I think like
just saying open ended feedback I can assume
like which question they're talking about
but I think if I were to just show this to
someone they wouldn't know like the like
open ended is just kind of like vague in
that case.
Okay Julia, you're giving me something two
interesting points here and let's actually
tackle your, your conversation about the
opponents. So in the open end question, so
people who select positive they get different
questions.
Those who select negative rating they get
different question and end like help me understand
why.
Why, like why showing that differentiation
is something that's important to you in the
summary. In the summary. Yeah,
probably because if I, if I wanted to take
this and just show it as it is to someone
who isn't within my CX like group they would
have no idea like what the questions are
on the survey. And if it just says open ended
feedback highlights opportunities then they're
going to think probably that all the open
ended feedback is negative. Whereas it's
probably just on that one question that you
only get if you rate the company negative.
So it's kind of just like a little misleading
in my opinion.
I see.
Yeah. So it's like giving your audience non
biased picture of.
Yeah.
Answer to open feedback is something that's
really critical like to, to the team.
Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
I mean because I could take this and like
change some stuff but I feel like that's
not the point of it, you know, that's not
the point of it.
Okay. That's actually something I want to
come back in the later conversation.
And Julia, you also mentioned that you really
love just looking at my note. You really
love the finding about.
Okay. The influencing customer satisfaction
is ability to resolve issues on the first
contact. Okay, help me understand what about
the finding makes you think, oh my God, I
love this. I love this insight.
Yeah.
So we've been striving for like a higher
rate of first contact resolution and trying
to define like, what can we do to like raise
this rate every year? Like looking at our
call volume, looking at our surveys, like
what people are saying, like why aren't,
why aren't things being solved on the first
time? How can we raise that? And this saying,
like the most critical factor influencing
like if people are happy or not is that first
call resolution. Like just is like really
like emphasizing what we already came up
with on our own.
Like people want their contact solved the
first time and it like really matters a lot.
And like we can pull that out, like we can
make that generalization. But this summary,
like saying that right off the bat is like
something that people higher than me would
like love to see for like some validation
for wanting to raise that first call resolution
rate.
Oh, I see. So Julia, help.
Okay, correct me if I am not accurately capturing
what you have just told me. So basically
that insight, the team already had like general
hypothesis that the, you know, the key factor
influencing customer satisfaction is to resolve
issues on the first context. So that was
the team's general hypothesis, but without
the need evidence. But, but with this survey
and the summary is giving you that exact
validation evidence that you're looking for,
which you can then take it to perhaps the
leadership or other cross functional partners.
Yes, exactly.
Makes sense. Okay, and is there anything
here that stands stands out to you as inaccurate
or accurate?
Like the whole report or just a summary?
Let's stick with this summary just for a
second.
Yeah.
Okay.
Other than the open ended feedback, like
maybe not being specific enough, I think
everything in the summary is accurate.
That makes sense. Okay, walk me through.
Start the overview section, please.
So, survey purpose, both survey purpose and
methodology, I don't have too much to say.
I think they're both completely accurate.
Like I wouldn't really change anything about
them.
That makes sense. And Julia, how useful do
you find this particular section in your
current role?
Like for me personally, I don't, I wouldn't
say like it's very useful because I already
know those things. But if I Wanted to share
this with someone else. They would probably
like, really like to see that. And it is,
I mean, it's helpful for me to like, say
without having to type it out myself. I could
just show this and say, like, this is our
purpose and methodology because it is accurate.
Like, it's not telling me anything that I
don't know, but it could tell people we share
it with something that they wouldn't have
known. Does that make sense?
Yeah, that makes sense. Okay, let's now help
me walk, please. Walk me through key finding
section, please.
Okay, I like this. I like this section especially
like these four here and then like, as kind
of like an overview. I thought that was helpful.
They're like, good for like quickly understanding
the results. And then if you go down, I like
to see these tables especially like that
you have the sample size there.
So we can see. Like, this isn't just based
on a few responses. Like, it's based on all
of them. Like, it's good to just see like
buckets of how many people are what are saying
what.
Like I said, first call resolution. It matters
a lot to us. So, like, this right here is
great to see that single contact drives best
outcomes. Honestly, I didn't focus too much
on these little paragraphs below the tables,
but it looks like they're kind of saying
the same things as above. Am I right?
So you are. You are definitely right. And
like, those additional they sometimes offer,
like, what's the next step you can take with
this finding a recommendation? And Julia,
I really love that you're talking about those,
those like the, the additional sentences
and when you look at them and please take
a few moments to like, read those additional
details. And I'm actually curious, like,
how do you feel about those additional explanations?
So, Yeah, that's great because it literally
says focusing on first of all, resolution
could reduce repeat inquiry. That's great.
That's like totally accurate. And everything
we've hypothesized on our own. I'm sorry
I didn't focus more on these ahead of time,
but these are really good because my department
is also combined with their training department.
So like, then this says training representatives
to consistently demonstrate understanding
and make customers feel valued could boost
satisfaction. Like, that is really helpful.
Help me understand why that particular phrase
is helpful.
I think, like, where we've been working on
some more training and improving our training
and figuring out like, where the gaps are.
So for this to say, like, we could boost
our satisfaction if we improve our training
pretty much is what I'm gathering it's saying
is then just again like validating what we
already thought but saying like if you boost
this question, you'll boost your overall
satisfaction. I think that's just helpful
because of validation.
Interesting. Okay, let's move to the 3 and
4. I'm curious about your thoughts on those
points as well.
I think these are, these are both good too.
Yeah, I'm not seeing anything that I would
like change or isn't helpful. It's definitely
helpful.
Okay, help me understand a little bit better.
Like what about that makes them helpful to
you and your team?
I think just kind of clarifying that like
if we're going to resolve your issue, it's
going to give the company a better reputation,
which sounds like kind of self explanatory.
But since it's actually taking the results
from the survey and like taking that generalization
out of it, I think that makes it helpful.
We could obviously kind of like pull that
generalization out ourselves maybe. But like
using the data to do that is helpful. And
then maybe for number four.
Oh, this is for sentiment, right?
Yeah,
sorry, go ahead.
No, I would say it looks like.
So, yeah, so yeah, I didn't. Oh actually
this is a good, this is good that this is
here because I wanted to say for the sentiment
feature, I have that turned on for I think
all of our comments and open ended questions,
I have it turned on and I do find myself
changing the sentiment sometimes more often
than not. Honestly like a lot of it I think
isn't picking up quite what the comment is
saying that.
Well, like it'll say the question will ask
like we ask a question, what can we do better?
And then the comment will say like hire good
representatives. And then the sentiment will
say positive. But what the customer is really
saying is you need to hire better representatives.
So then I end up changing that sentiment
a lot.
And I know that it's just basing it off the
comments so it doesn't really like. I guess
I can't really like pick up what they're
saying. But I just wanted to mention that
because I feel like that's good to know.